[Music]
for example WWE Monday Night Raw yeah I
was watching that and then I put on the
info button and put on the info button
it says men in tights wrestle with their
sexuality check this out I DVR'd
yesterday's 49er Packers football game
and I was curious so I pushed the info
button and it said football watched by a
crowd too fat to know they're cold yeah
that's a that's a dick in the eye
yeah what the hell before guys are lying
yeah I I watched Aqua Teen Hunger Force
and her fever yeah yeah and I was
curious what the info but would say so I
pressing it said when you're too stoned
for spongebob
[Applause]
that is the next level of stone - oh
yeah
million dollar listing check tout
million dollar listing yeah and I push
the info button it said already hate
your trailer park watch this and go on a
killing spree
very nice Dance Moms I checked out Dance
Moms you seen this show yeah
no yeah I push the info button and it
said soon to be known by Child
Protective Services as Exhibit A
I thought I'd watch our own show I
checked out Conan I I know this show
yeah and I pushed the info button
because I was curious and it said lanky
Irish American seeks the love he never
got from his parents
[Music]
making people clap it's real funny
[Laughter]
the Victoria's Secret Fashion Show I
watched that yeah and this is what it's
done the info button it said this is the
only boner you'll get watching CBS okay
yeah that's just true a Mad Money with
Jim Cramer check that show out yeah yeah
look what it said push the info button
louis c.k gets rabies and then gives
financial
what it is the sing-off I checked out
the sing-off yeah push the info button
nope that's arch for NBC hey Khloe Lamar
I watched Khloe and Lamar yeah then I
push the info button a show about how
marriage between two men doesn't
you know what show you are coming to see
no hey Joan and Melissa let's watch Joan
and Melissa yeah let see what it says
info button a show stirring an older
melting ice cream cone and a younger man
ice cream yeah
and finally duck dynasty yeah there's
duck dynasty check out the info button
it says anti-gay hunters spend all their
time blowing on long cylinder
[Applause]